[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional de france
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en la
recuperación económica tras la crisis
sanitaria y las diferentes recetas
aplicadas en distintos países del mundo
para ello nos acompañan hoy una
investigadora un periodista y un
economista de salud o eulalia rubio
investigadora del instituto jacques
delors experta en asuntos como
presupuestos de la unión europea o
políticas de cohesión bienvenida eulalia
hola bien muchas gracias miguel martínez
es corresponsal de tv azteca aquí en
parís bienvenido a miguel qué tal
muchas gracias y en dúplex david
marguerite que economista del instituto
de luxemburgo de investigaciones
socioeconómicas y presidente del think
tank european data la davis buenos días
buenos días que nos encantados de estar
aquí con vosotros relanzamiento
económico hoy en primera plana
la recuperación económica mundial tras
la pandemia del coronavirus se ha
acelerado pero avanza de manera desigual
entre los países y enfrentan múltiples
desafíos siendo el más grave sin duda la
falta de vacunas en los países pobres
esa es la conclusión que se deriva del
reporte más reciente de la organización
para la cooperación y el desarrollo
económico es la ocde que acaba de ser
publicado las medidas de rescate y
estímulo económico en los países
desarrollados han sido la clave para
devolver al carril del crecimiento el
organismo cifra el crecimiento para este
año en curso en el 58 por ciento ello
comparado con la contracción del 35
registrada el año pasado a nivel mundial
hasta qué punto estas estimaciones nos
dibujan un escenario optimista hoy
hablaremos de las recetas que los
diferentes países están aplicando para
salir de esta crisis pero antes
repasemos algunas portadas que nos deja
la prensa the economist la gran apuesta
de bailén y lo que significa su
multimillonario plan de estímulos para
la economía mundial la opinión de lance
mundial la ecuación de 11 incógnitas que
desarrolla este diario diciendo
otro del planeta los gobiernos
desarrollan diversas estrategias para
salir de la crisis coincide el italiano
la repubblica bajo el título el estado
de la recuperación explicando como
realidades como las variantes como por
ejemplo la india llamada hora delta en
reino unido pueden poner en peligro los
planes de reapertura bueno el área
podemos decir en términos generales que
la recuperación va tomando forma yo creo
que sí e la ocde y también la comisión
europea en sus proyecciones económicas
nos dicen que estamos entrando en la
recuperación pero por ejemplo una cosa
que dice la ucedé también es que es una
recuperación desigual como las dicho no
todos los estados están yendo al mismo
ritmo y fuera de lo común porque es una
crisis también fuera de lo común o es
una crisis financiera como las que
estamos acostumbrados y entonces hay
muchos interrogantes por ejemplo la
cuestión de las variantes hasta qué
punto no vamos a caer otra vez en
problemas de vacunas del año que viene
también hay esta interrogante del ahorro
las familias han ahorrado mucho en esta
crisis y no se sabe muy bien los
economistas lo sabe muy bien sí
y ahora empezará todo el mundo consumir
como antes o habrá un poco menos de más
dificultades o la gente no se atreviera
tanto a emprender con el consumo de
antes o sea que hay bastantes
interrogantes aún hablemos de esta parte
del consumo
-miguel corresponsal aquí en francia y
qué ambiente hay en la calle en francia
ahora que se han vuelto a reabrir las
terrazas los bares el nivel de ganas de
consumo sí sí sí yo creo que después de
la reapertura del descongelamiento por
parte del gobierno francés a francia
y la reapertura de estos bares pues
habla mucho de la necesidad sobre todo
en la sociedad de poder salir de poder
desahogarse un poco de toda esta
situación por la que hemos vivido
durante este periodo que todavía no
concluye también hay que decirlo también
hay que ser muy claros con esto que
todavía no está muy claro cómo va cuál
va a ser el verdadero plan de salida de
crisis de coronavirus y también la
recuperación económica en una más tiene
que ser que si vamos a abrir bares
quisimos abrir restaurantes que íbamos a
abrir centros comerciales también deben
de ir acompañados
a más largo plazo a nuevas reformas de
protección a los trabajadores debe de
haber una menor dependencia también
sobre productos no es decir contra china
pero han mostrado esta crisis una
dependencia de todos los países hay no
hay excepción de todos los países una
dependencia tanto de tecnología como de
todos los materiales básicos de china
entonces si lo comparamos con materiales
como las mascarillas en los vicios de la
crisis que europa no entonces todo eso
debe cierto la reapertura la gente está
saliendo la gente está consumiendo en
gracia pero yo creo que es una
reactivación económica a muy corto plazo
por no decir que nada más únicamente
abarcará el periodo de verano después
tienen que venir nuevas reformas y mayor
protección de los trabajadores que esta
crisis ha mostrado con las desigualdades
que se han presentado y la necesidad de
mayor protección a los trabajadores en
europa existe hay que reforzarlo y en
américa latina hay que ponerlo porque es
indispensable nos vemos en méxico lo
vemos en colombia anualmente por la
crisis que está atravesando entonces
esta situación
un nuevo vamos a decir una nueva agenda
política en la región vamos a irnos
hasta el luxemburgo con david marketing
de economista del isr y presidente del
think tank european data lab david de
que factores va a depender que la
economía mundial consolide esta
recuperación a la que apuntan
instituciones como la ocde podemos
identificar estos factores muy
importante para recuperar de la pandemia
el primer factor es la organización de
una de una compañía de vacunación muy
eficiente queremos salir de este sitio
de sión donde la población no puede
salir de su casa y no puede consumir
necesitamos a consumir que le progresan
consumen más el segundo factor
es que los gobiernos tienen que mantener
sus políticas fiscales y también
presupuestarias
porque queremos evitar que las empresas
quiebran y que tenemos una cantidad de
desempleados
más importante en el futuro el último
factor es los bancos centrales que lo
tienen en tener sus políticas e inyectar
mucho dinero en la economía para tener
tasas de interés bajo y que los países
puedan para que los países puedan
y pidió prestados baratos
y con ello la ocede dice que nunca antes
en una crisis se habíamos visto
políticas públicas tan rápidas y
eficaces tanto en materia de salud como
en estímulos
eulalia usted que conoce también la
unión europea se ha reaccionado más
eficazmente en esta crisis que en otras
como por ejemplo la crisis de la deuda
hace ya más de diez años yo creo que sí
tenemos que tenemos que separar entre la
la respuesta sanitaria a la crisis de la
respuesta económica la sanitaria
evidentemente ha habido algunos errores
en la campaña en la estrategia de
vacunación del año europea pero también
se tiene que tener en cuenta que la
unión europea no tiene competencias en
salud y era una cosa totalmente nueva le
estábamos pidiendo hacer una cosa nueva
en cuanto a la respuesta económica
no hay color con lo que pasó en la
crisis de la zona euro de hecho hemos
tenido una banco central que ha
reaccionado muy rápido que ha puesto en
marcha un programa de
de compra de deuda pública muy rápido y
hemos tenido a nivel presupuestario una
respuesta muy importante con este next
generation you cuando en la crisis
anterior estábamos en un clima de
austeridad y nos tardamos muchos meses a
poner en marcha el primer plan de apoyo
a grecia es decir que hemos aprendido y
a veces solo nos fijamos en el next
generation' y/o pero no es sólo eso a
nivel de muchas políticas europeas se ha
puesto en marcha muchas cosas para
permitir a los estados miembros gastar
tanto cuánto necesitaban por ejemplo se
han relajado las se ha suspendido el
pacto de estabilidad y crecimiento
permitiendo a los estados de endeudarse
más y se han relajado también las reglas
de ayuda de ayudas de estado que también
es una manera de permitir a los estados
de gastar más es decir ha habido como un
cambio de paradigma también a nivel
europeo decir hay una crisis tenemos que
reaccionar tenemos que poner el dinero
necesario y lo vamos a hacer rápido una
crisis que en cambio si lo nos vamos al
otro lado del atlántico y lo comparamos
con américa latina'
miguel va a tardar muchos más años y
puede acrecentar los ya potentes niveles
de desigualdad que hay en la región si
no lo hemos visto
creo que los organismos de naciones
unidas en una región calcularon que 22
millones de personas entraron a la
pobreza en 2020 en américa latina'
vemos por ejemplo que el ac decía por
ejemplo perdón a que países como
argentina se recuperará en 2026 es decir
comparado con europa si están teniendo y
habla justamente esto que decía la
protección a los trabajadores no es lo
mismo en mexico colombia en todos los
países de américa latina es imposible
fue casi imposible poner en marcha un
confinamiento estricto debido a que más
de la mitad de la población activa está
en el comercio informal entonces cuando
uno confinado cuando la gente no puede
salir a trabajar informalmente bueno no
está recibiendo ningún ningún
presupuesto no está recibiendo ningún
ningún insumo entonces esto habla
también de la problemática que sigue en
la región y va a tener mucho mucho
problema de recuperación económica y
bueno méxico va a jugar un rol también
importante en materia de vacunación que
eso lo vemos más vamos a irnos hasta
luxemburgo david margaritas que porque
la administración baiden afronta la
pandemia con ambiciosos programas de
estímulo que impulsa en eeuu en su
competición con china mientras la unión
europea apuesta por medidas más
expansivas que la de la crisis de 2008
pero no equiparables
de las superpotencias todo indica todo
indica que eeuu saldrá antes y mejor que
europa de esta crisis david
sí claro todos los indicadores indican
que los eeuu van a salir más rápidamente
más fuerte de la de la pandemia que las
países de europea los estados unidos
están ahora recuperando el nivel del
aire que tenían antes de la pandemia
esto se explica más por el plano que
está muy muy importante en los eeuu el
plano de estímulo el programa de
estímulo y que se focaliza mucho en las
familias en las personas para que
consumen más y también los eeuu han
empezado más también más temprano y más
rápidamente más fuerte la campaña de
vacunación
y que ahora tenemos como 50% de la
población que han recibido una dosis de
vacunas en los stand eeuu con cada
cambio 38% por ejemplo en diferencia en
españa
eulalia miguel les ha sorprendido esta
faceta de tanto estímulo por parte del
presidente joe biden porque no lo
podíamos imaginar comparado con donald
trump pero no sé si a este hasta este
nivel de estímulo bueno efectivamente
sorprendido bailén además era el
candidato más moderado ante entre los
demócratas y nadie se esperaba que fuera
que tomara un impulso tan importante yo
creo que detrás de esta decisión es una
decisión basada en análisis económicos
de vamos a intentar estimular la
economía de una forma muy clara pero
también hay una lectura política de eso
yo creo que vayan y los demócratas en
cierta medida estén intentando
satisfacer a están intentando convencer
una parte de la población popular que
fue una parte del electorado de trump
creo que también tenemos que entender
esto que hay detrás pero efectivamente
hay un cambio de paradigma económico en
eeuu
a ustedes aprender también me he sido
bastante sorprendente pero bueno también
habla de un una parte de que este
sistema por el que estamos atravesando
del antes y después de la crisis
sanitaria el sistema económico
capitalista vamos a decirlo no es que
está llegando a su fin pero está
teniendo una hay una nueva modalidad que
bueno ahora eeuu se da cuenta que cuando
los trabajadores son esenciales en las
empresas las empresas no son nada sin
los trabajadores y que hay que estimular
ante una crisis como ésta que es también
excepcional como crisis pero bueno hay
que hay que mostrar esa protección a los
trabajadores y estimular a la economía
bueno dando dando presupuestos crítico
nunca se había visto para eeuu
inyectando vamos a hacer una breve pausa
y a vuelta continuamos hablando de la
recuperación económica post pandémica
hay que en primera plana
[Música]
y
bienvenidos a un nuevo avance
informativo en france 24 les traemos una
programación más corta debido a la
contingencia por coronavirus en bogotá
colombia en donde están ubicados
nuestros estudios
estamos inició en brasil el regulador de
la salud
anvisa aprobó las importaciones de las
vacunas rusas sputnik y la india- kóvacs
inah pero con restricciones una de ellas
que se use sólo en adultos sanos
en abril la vacuna rusa había sido
rechazada porque la agencia consideraba
que no había suficiente información
sobre su efectividad y en marzo lo había
hecho con kóvacs y por qué no cumplía
con los estándares de fabricación
brasilia ha inoculado con dos dosis a
casi 23 millones de personas un poco más
del 10% de su población
seguimos en argentina allí la cifra de
muertos por kobe de 19
pere los 80 mil el país de registró este
viernes 539 muertes y 30 mil 950
contagios que llevan el total de
contagios a 39 millones la mientras la
ciudadanía se prepara para un nuevo
confinamiento de este sábado y domingo
el presidente alberto fernández anunció
durante una videoconferencia con su para
ruso vladimir putin el inicio de la
producción local de la vacuna rusa
sputnik
por parte del laboratorio privado
richemont
hoy empezamos ya el trabajo concreto
para empezar a producir en argentina les
publique
el día domingo si dios quiere un avión
estará partiendo de moscú
trayendo el principio activo para que
empiece la producción en argentina de
inmediato
el principio activo que el instituto de
gamal ella nos proveerá y eeuu españa y
francia se sumaron a la presión
internacional al presidente de nicaragua
daniel ortega para que gestionen la
liberación de la líder opositora
cristiana chamorro la también aspirante
presidencial quien intentará minar los
esfuerzos de ortega para obtener un
octavo período presidencial lleva tres
días de recluida en su vivienda desde el
miércoles bajo un fuerte esquema de
vigilancia policial la justicia la acusa
de lavado de dinero y otros delitos por
su rol en la clausurada ong fundación
violeta barrios de chamorro
y daniel ortega el ex presidente de eeuu
donald trump calificó de censura abuso e
insulto a los 75 millones de personas
que votaron por el la decisión de la
plataforma facebook de suspender su
cuenta al menos hasta enero de 2023
facebook suspendió la cuenta de trompe
tras los disturbios del 6 de enero donde
un grupo de seguidores radicales del
republicano se tomó las instalaciones
del capitolio nacional en washington el
veto sólo se levantará si facebook
considera que el riesgo para la
seguridad pública ha disminuido la casa
blanca insistió en la responsabilidad de
los gigantes tecnológicos en la lucha
contra la desinformación y lanzó
críticas al ex presidente
el gobierno de nigeria anunció la
suspensión indefinida de las actividades
de la red social 'twitter' en el país lo
hizo dos días después de que el gigante
estadounidense eliminara una publicación
del presidente muhammadu buhari en la
que amenazaba con castigar a los
separatistas regionales la empresa
argumentó que el gobierno nigeriano
había violado su política de
comportamiento abusivo y tildó la
suspensión de profundamente preocupante
con eso finalizamos yo los invito a que
se queden con nosotros en france 24 y en
france 24 puntos
[Música]
continuamos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de la recuperación económica
post pandemia con eulalia rubio
investigadora del instituto jacques
delors experta en asuntos como
presupuestos unión europea o políticas
de cohesión con miguel martínez
periodista corresponsal de tv azteca y
en dúplex desde luxemburgo david
marguerite economista del instituto de
luxemburgo de investigaciones
socioeconómicas el isr y presidente del
think tank european data la hablamos
antes de la recuperación intentamos
hacer esas comparativas no de la
recuperación en eeuu y de la
recuperación en europa
hablamos con david de como si
normalmente esa recuperación va a verse
se va a ver mucho más claramente
reflejada en el caso de eeuu antes y
mejor de una forma más robusta quizá
también hay que entender que la
capacidad de la economía estadounidense
para rebotar es mucho mayor que la
europea por qué por qué por qué tiene
más flexibilidad no quizá hay una parte
de eso es verdad que en los mercados de
trabajo más flexibles el que la creación
de empleo llega antes que en otros
mercados de trabajo pero también hay que
entender que en el caso de eeuu no hay
qué
no hay que olvidar que parte del éxito
que tiene la hora de recuperación es por
la campaña de vacunación claro más que
por la economía antiguo o el estímulo
económico ha llegado a un poco más tarde
el estímulo económico y perdonables
hacemos la comparativa con europa justo
en ese punto que errores ha cometido
europa en europa eeuu tuvo se crearon
esta campaña world en la que no sólo
compraron las vacunas sino que pusieron
mucho dinero para que para la producción
de las vacunas y se dieron muy se dieron
cuenta muy rápidamente de que que hacía
falta que el estado tomara mucho riesgo
que no era sólo una cuestión de hacer un
contrato con nada con una empresa que
hace las vacunas y comprar las vacunas
sino que tenía que poner el dinero para
la fábrica para la investigación y para
la fabricación de las vacunas entonces
es la estrategia de vacunación de eeuu
en comparación con la de europa la
europa fue más ir a comprar vacunas y
hacer grandes contratos de vacunas ya
realizadas pero no europa fallo
quizás en no darse cuenta de lo
el desafío de producción de las vacunas
que producirá grandes las vacunas es
difícil y que hacía falta que el estado
se pusiera también en esto y que ayudará
también las empresas a hacer esta
pregunta es david marguerite eeuu y by
the end and comprendido al menos mejor
que europa que la carrera de la
recuperación la ganarán los países que
menos tarden en vacunar y los que más
dinero destinen a ayudas a familias y
empresas a salir del abismo en el que
les ha sumido el virus
durante toda la pandemia lo que hemos
visto es que la gente
y ahora con mucho dinero tenían miedo
del futuro no sabían si en el año
próximo lo tendrían todavía su trabajo
por ejemplo han puesto mucho mucho
dinero en el banco y ahora lo que falta
en la economía es la demanda es que las
empresas tienen que ver una demanda y
una vez que verán esta demanda van a
producir más y vamos a entonces hay que
ser ameno
hay que pelearla el nivel del pib que
teníamos antes y por tener esto primero
tenemos que vacunar a mucha gente lo más
rápidamente posible los gobiernos tienen
que ayudar a las personas que han estado
afectado más por la pandemia y que por
ejemplo que ahora están desempleados o
cosas así y que necesitan dinero para
consumir porque las personas con menos
recursos ya sabemos que las personas con
menos recursos consumen más cuando le
damos un euro que las personas más ricas
que consumen menos hablamos del ritmo de
esta campaña de vacunación y volviendo a
mirar a américa latina y en concreto a
su país méxico miguel la ocde decía en
su informe de esta semana méxico que
tiene que acelerar en la campaña de
vacunación para revitalizar la
recuperación económica cómo va esa
campaña qué problemas tiene la cuestión
hay que entender que en méxico como los
países ricos pues no ha tenido el
impacto el suficiente presupuesto para
comprar estas estas vacunas no es como
eeuu como inglaterra pero bueno se han
se han puesto las pilas en este momento
méxico lleva más del 22 por ciento de su
población por lo menos ya vacunada y
otro de las cuestiones que por el cual
méxico bajo un rol bastante importante
junto con argentina también en la región
de américa latina y el caribe es que
ellos van a producir vacunas entonces en
este momento por ejemplo creo que es
cansino y astrazéneca que ya están
siendo producidas en méxico y
próximamente a finales del mes de junio
será sputnik que la vacuna rusa a dos
dosis y la nueva vacuna rusa a una dosis
que va a ser fabricada en mexico en un
primer tiempo para
esta campaña de vacunación de mexico que
es bastante importante para el
relanzamiento económico también y
después para poder dar y entregar
vacunas a otros países de américa de
américa latina que están en muchísimas
dificultades pienso por ejemplo en
paraguay que apenas van creo que 30.000
personas vacunadas desde una sola dosis
entonces habla bastante de la
desigualdad que se está viviendo en este
momento no sólo en materia económica
sino también de que los países no están
no están vacunando al mismo ritmo en
áfrica
la misma situación en los países
asiáticos también entonces esto va a ser
va a ser va a tener un rol bastante
importante y méxico ha entrado en esta
capacidad de vacunar que es de vacunar
de fabricar vacunas que es podríamos ver
lo contrario a lo que está por ejemplo
francia que tiene una gran empresa como
es
y ni siquiera por el momento no producen
ninguna vacuna y bueno méxico ya anda
produciendo otras vacunas 4 vacunas y es
bastante hablabas antes de los
trabajadores informales entendemos que
las mujeres los trabajadores informales
y los más jóvenes han sido los más
afectados en términos de empleo en
américa latina lo dice también la ocde
me imagino que ese es el gran reto de la
región en la etapa de recuperación
integrar estos sectores que han sido los
más perjudicados por la crisis las
mujeres sobre todo sobre todas las
mujeres porque hay una brecha de género
muy importante hay muchos factores de
entrada del 15 al principio la
protección de los trabajadores en méxico
se intentó hacer una reforma el año
pasado para eliminar el outsourcing o
las subcontrataciones que que esto no
permite a los trabajadores tener una
cotización
digna para su futuro se trata de
eliminar y méxico debe de eliminar esto
para que los trabajadores puedan cotizar
de una manera digna de otra otra parte
también que a mí me parece bastante
importante es que hay un sector un nuevo
sector de estudiantes que terminaron sus
estudios que iban a entrar al mercado
laboral en 2020 y que ellos estaban
totalmente fuera de el mercado en este
momento y eso es una parte de la
población bastante importante que
tendremos que tomar en cuenta a futuro
porque el impacto de la crisis todavía
no lo podemos ver a ciencia cierta
estamos hablando de un reloj de una
reactivación económica pero bueno
detrás hay varios factores como los
estudiantes que se están quedando atrás
y fuera del mercado laboral vamos a
hablar de esa brecha económica que deje
el virus en américa latina con david
marguerite desde luxemburgo porque
imaginamos que tardaran david muchos
años en recuperarse de esta brecha en
américa latina' la pandilla agrandará en
términos generales estas brechas a nivel
mundial
es que la américa latina está muy
afectada para la pandemia y tomará mucho
mucho tiempo para los países de allá de
pelar de este de esta pandemia y creo
que el único caso que está un poquito
diferente es el chile y ya tienen
bastante personas vacunando como un 50
55% con jatnna 19% por el continente por
ejemplo y
y también tiene un plano para la ayuda a
la economía es bastante fuerte vamos a
claramente vamos a tener una brecha más
importante antes bueno los países más
ricos y los países de américa latina
porque bueno necesitan más más años para
recuperar de la crisis volviendo aquí
europa los planes de desescalada están
intentando adaptarse paralelamente a
esta recuperación económica dominará el
virus para al mismo tiempo reabrir y
reactivar la economía eulalia creen que
se han adecuado bien estas dos
realidades en países como francia bueno
esto es un gran desafío de hecho es
verdad que hablamos mucho del plan de
recuperación pero en paralelo tenemos
que salir de la crisis y tenemos que
terminar con todas esas medidas de
perfusión a la economía que hemos
mantenido durante mucho tiempo en france
y en muchos países europeos esto es
ahora mismo está está en plena discusión
cómo hacerlo de forma progresiva de
forma inteligente también para evitar
que empresas por ejemplo que sean
viables puedan reemprender la actividad
pero que tampoco el estado
acabe financiando empresas que ya no
tienen viabilidad
y no es fácil de hecho en las noticias
de francia vemos que empiezan a haber
planes de cómo identificar las buenas en
las malas empresas de las empresas que
vale la pena mantener las que no es un
desafío importante y en todos los países
donde ha habido sobre todo los países
como francia donde ha habido mucha ayuda
pública que se han mantenido durante
mucho tiempo mucha actividad económica
mantenida con un apoyo del estado es un
gran reto y se tiene que hacer en
paralelo al reto de la recuperación
económica celular esta recuperación
puede potenciar realmente la economía
sostenible y dar impulso a la economía
digital atendiendo a los proyectos
presentados durante estos últimos meses
por los países ante la comisión de la
unión europea para conseguir los fondos
de recuperación yo creo que sí y éste
también es el gran reto de hecho es lo
que intenta ahora con el plan de
recuperación europea y este plan de
recuperación
está condicionado 38 por ciento de la
ayuda tiene que ir a la inversión sobre
temas climáticos y un 22 20 por ciento
del equipo en temas digitales y es una
gran apuesta también europeo y si lo
comparamos por ejemplo con vaivén que
siempre hablamos de esta comparación de
talla pues en eeuu vemos un poco menos
desde esta condicionalidad la ayuda va a
ir en ha sido más genérica no no está
tan condicionada hay un poco menos de
esfuerzo de esto que dicen bounce back
better de intentar que la recuperación
no sea como volver a la normalidad de
antes creo que esto en esto en europa sí
que se distinga un poco de eeuu
y también esta cuestión de inyectar
dinero a las grandes empresas debería
tomarlos con pincitas también porque el
año pasado vimos por ejemplo el gobierno
francés cuando anunció la recuperación
inyectar dinero y apoyo al sector
aeronáutico airbus y air france
precisamente que les dieron más de 15
mil millones de dólares de euros y estas
empresas después de estos anuncios
despidieron o anunciaron un despido
masivo de casi 20.000 personas entonces
esto tiene que estar y tiene que ser
regulado también porque dar dinero tanto
dinero a un sector y después este sector
empieza a despedir masivamente a las
personas y sobre el circuito sobre las
cuestiones de los supermercados vamos a
decir yo creo que la economía de
circuitos cortos yo creo que va a tener
para retomar un poco las riendas en el
consumo de supermercados porque vimos
que durante los confinamientos se
presentaban desabastos de productos
básicos en francia- específicamente y
nacieron en estas pequeñas los pequeños
agricultores que los supermercados
tuvieron que acudir a los a los pequeños
agricultores para poder abastecer y
tener sus productos básicos en el
supermercado nos vamos a ir me queda muy
poquito tiempo pero antes me gustaría
comentar os la que la onu resume tres
tendencias en este periodo de
recuperación de recuperación sí pero
desigual la situación aún más precaria
de los vulnerables ya que la pandemia de
empujado a 114 millones de personas a la
pobreza extrema y la vertiente de género
con mujeres y niñas más afectadas las
mujeres que se hacen cargo también de
los cuidados con ella es decir son las
tres tendencias que dibuja la onu
claramente estas tres líneas básicas de
de recuperación en la que los países
deberán trabajar muchísimas gracias
eulalia miguel david y a todos ustedes
les esperamos aquí en primera plana la
próxima semana en radio francia
internacional y france 24 gracias